and then also I don't like talking about
showbiz no more on the on the podcast
but Friday night out for the first time
oh you're laughing nothing Friday night
for the first time alright so I I'm a
part of Annie I have agents you guys
know that right yeah yeah and they
invited me to this Emmy party okay
fancy I've never been invited to it the
first thing I do is will show up I see
iliza shlesinger
I see Matt Braunger I see all these
comics they go we come every year and
I've never been invited which destroyed
me kind of brent morin how I make my
deals at this party but then um we had a
good time it was uh was fun you guys did
not only was it star-studded I get it
now that's the club oh the club you're
talking about
that's the clucky I mean like I knew it
was the club because I ran into my one
and only Hall Pass whoa damn me who
bright more like [ __ ] putting a
[ __ ] hole in the back of my head
Edgar Ramirez you could suck his dick I
don't give a [ __ ] we were shoulder to
shoulder and he looked at me once and
then Bobbi is like he's not he didn't
give me permission initially he did he
was a he wasn't on the list
he is andhe little bit I never heard his
name before it so it's like oh you can't
put him on the list but tell me now I
have an actual is at the write it down
his name so you have Tom Hardy on there
you got [ __ ] um who else is on there
um Kit Harington kid Harrington yeah Jon
Snow's on there Edgar Ramirez okay now
I'm gonna put Edgar Ramirez on that's
here's Sean arts okay okay look the
likelihood of me actually running into
these people are slim to none right so
that's why I knew this was the club
because I was like oh my god Edgar
Ramirez is right next to me yeah I can
smell him my Hall Pass is right here I
can make a deal if I want like he's way
too hot he would never even but I'm just
say
in my brain oh I would you know what I
would love you try to hit on him I would
have part of me to listen and him reject
you I would have went on the ground
I'm sort of involved I like laughing
like I would I would a laugh right in
your [ __ ] face I would never never I
worry that if he goes yeah but let's go
do it I'll be like hey just long as I
can tape oh speaking of taping was a
really bad dream you guys Oh dreams suck
is it bad poetry I hate it no explain
okay so I I dreamt that I got
scopolamine the Burrow Donga like you
did in Colombia and I dreamt that some
people coerced me to make a sex tape you
know without me knowing basically I was
like a zombie okay and then they
released it on the interwebs and then
they basically I told Bobby and then he
didn't believe me that I was raped and
he was like no you cheated on me I can
see you were enjoying it on camera and I
was like no I was brewed on God and then
he was like no no something that's
[ __ ] and he broke up because how
could there have no way to prove if you
were brought down good or not if I'm I'm
marching a tape yeah and you're like
going yes I'm going to swallow it or
what you see my eyes you know I'm gonna
be like yeah she's into it yeah if
you're tied up and you're passed out
then but thing about dongha you know
[ __ ] you George for introducing bird on
the door alone add another element to
this yeah I didn't want to yeah
so even if you're raped in your burrow
dongha just don't put yourself in that
situation
yeah like that don't let that happen
where a man like okay someone's like hey
sir can you show me on this map like had
Shire she did that to Hulk Hogan he
backed up and he didn't get sprayed mmm
yeah dude like what did that dust
inhalation anthrax come on Bobby
[ __ ] you all right Edgar Ramirez he's on
the list you won't get three and that's
it who's on your list I have nobody
because I love you you're the only one
in my life I shut the [ __ ] up Oh another
another season what happened at the
party well
just remember how we were talking about
when you know first year of our
relationship Bobby would do [ __ ] up
things to me like he would text other
women like hey I'd [ __ ] you without a
condom I draw dog-ear whatever you guys
first started dating yeah yeah yeah I
maybe a year into it and then we haven't
yeah we would would fight about it don't
say the name I wouldn't I'm not gonna
say the name Jessica Chastain no but she
was there at the CAA party there damn
that Jessica's Josh Chastain but the
girl that all the girls yeah yeah anyway
she was there but she gave me give me a
big hug and she was like but this is how
[ __ ] fake women are she knew that we
were in a relationship when she was
writing and flirting with Bobby in that
way but when she saw me she was like oh
my god Bobby she's way too hot for you
hi how are you I'm trying to be really
sweet with me yeah in my mind I'm like
you Hollywood ass political [ __ ] I know
what the [ __ ] you've been texting him
you know but but what did I do
I said you guys catch up I'll go grab a
drink and I like just exited I didn't
try to make my she's not on my list
don't know why she was ever but I know
do the girl know that you knew no that's
the past what are we even talking about
right here but there's this there's a
feeling of power when I Van Der Beek's
comes
[Music]